what's your name I ma'am hi my name is
Deshawn so I kind of started between New
York and then he said my first interest
business way back in 1998 I'm gonna pick
up two aspects of all you talked about
first thing you said was when marketers
get to something they kill it yes
don't eat it so second you talked about
the Facebook back pages yes
I recently book tickets and hotel room
in England post my booking my facebook
newsfeed was certainly filled with
offers of hotels in London that's right
it pissed me off correct don't you think
Facebook is now over marketing itself to
the last point we had that is becoming
an invasion of privacy where I actually
raised my hand and said don't call me
send me a text if you want me to call
call you back
not yet why do you say that because I
look at the sales the numbers the only
reason your theory as I setup is 100
percent correct that they will come if
Facebook stops innovating Facebook
impresses the [ __ ] out of me they're the
only company that has continued to
innovate when they started going into
not showing every pages stuff everybody
complained what I realized they were
doing was they're trying to protect the
thing they care about which is they
don't want to piss you off you decided
to be pissed off by that and that's
great and I don't disagree and as
everybody gets good at this and
everybody does it that will happen the
reason I tell you that I don't agree
right now is because I'm looking at the
numbers we have growth in conversion not
decline decline will come decline will
come in 15 or 16 and 17 and then I'll
look at it and I'll be like AHA decline
and then I'll start worrying about some
other [ __ ] so but what I do know is that
SCM is down 17% and click-throughs this
month that Google AdWords which I would
have sat here in 2003 and yelled a bat
and I would have said would have been
ruined and you would have asked me you
know I don't click them as much anymore
because I used to like when Google was
clean and I would say you're right
and I'd say but not yet and you'd say
why do you say that and I would say
because I see the numbers and then that
decline started happening in 2012
because we got behavior eyes right and
so that's my answer my friend
Marketing in the year that we live in
too many people project what's gonna
happen too many people don't want to
agree with what's happening I don't give
a [ __ ] I just care about right now
you're a buddy dude what's your name
Scott Scott your buddy dick the
Instagram snapchat see ya see you know
like how did you land him as a client
did you use things like Instagram and
snapchat or did use you know old-school
methods to Lantana so I like you what's
your name again
Scott Scott I appreciate it this is a
great great great great question the
answer is both him
word of mouth of another client the work
we did word of mouth
oh by the way if you're curious with
social medias it's the plumbing of
word-of-mouth in our current society if
you're wondering but to answer your
question because I know where you're
going let me paint you a picture of the
4.7 million dollar account that I just
landed using social media only in a way
that nobody thinks about social media so
there was a CMO of a company I really
wanted to get to right and have no real
angle you know I have a big brand so a
lot comes to me but I wanted this one it
was strategic for a lot of reasons so I
followed him on Twitter if who's in b2b
raise your hand awesome so most of you
are sitting here and saying cool but for
b2b it's different let me explain how
it's not different
I built a huge b2c business I'm
currently building a huge b2b business
I'm both I'm really not prejudiced to
either I promise you
b2b is easier let me explain why unlike
b2c you know the [ __ ] name of the
person you're selling to let me just say
that one more time
you literally know who the [ __ ] you're
selling to whether you know their name
you definitely know their title it's
ludicrous I'm so pissed that I was in
b2c for all those years this PETA betien
is [ __ ] awesome so I do this every
time any time I want to sell to somebody
in a b2b context I take their name I go
to something called Google I put it in I
hit the spacebar and I hit Twitter and I
find their Twitter account 30 to 40
percent of the time that person is on
Twitter sometimes not that's okay but
this time that
was and then I started following them
and I didn't hit them up with a tweet
and say hey check me out hey check out
vaynermedia Hey look at all this insane
work we're doing for GE or Ritz or all
that stuff I didn't do those things
uh-huh I didn't try to throw a right
hook on the first date right I didn't do
that
nope what I did was I listened and I
found out Scott that this guy is a huge
st. Louis Cardinals fan because that's
what he talked about and so when I
started doing Scott was doing all the
same stuff that you and I have been
doing for 20 years but we've been doing
them over steak dinners and golf and
really inefficient ways like that and I
started using Twitter to listen to what
this person cared about and I started
mapping his emotions and when you map
somebody's emotions you can exploit them
for sales so I started talking to this
guy about randomly I wonder if I drafted
kolten Wong on purpose or because I was
strategic but I drafted kolten Wong
upstarts second baseman of the st. Louis
Cardinals on my fantasy baseball team
and I started talking to him about
kolten Wong which made it very easy for
him to look at my profile and see that I
was the CEO of a social media agency at
a time where he was debating the value
of his got it and every person in this
room can do it but it takes patience it
takes time it takes being a great
salesperson
you know what a great salesperson is a
listener most people suck because all
they're doing is closing short-term most
of sales people that drive great results
for me suck because they're short term
players it's just the clothes they're
incentivized on the bonus on the clothes
that's in front of them life and
building actual wealth and building an
actual business is a marathon it's an
Ironman not a sprint
all right and so that's what I do so I
know where your question went and I can
tell you right now I like them both I
love being here I wish I didn't have to
run and could stay 15 minutes
shake a hand get a biz dev I can live on
that I grew up with that I love that I
do the same
[ __ ] at scale on these platforms same
feeling you're gonna tell me when you I
love when people like well it's not the
same emotion I'm like really a letter
that was written to you didn't have any
emotion in it you don't get any emotion
shirt tone can be lost in a text or in
an email tone can be lost in a
face-to-face conversation too so that's
the answer
hi hi Gary I'm Joe hey Joe
so first of all thank you very much
you're awesome appreciate further I
would like to ask you a question can I
come up to the stage and do a selfie
with you and the holy Oh behind us
because I'm part of the communications
of Brooklyn and New York and it would be
really awesome to do that it'll just
take a minute yes thank you let's clap
it up with ass man
so I have something called a selfie pole
yeah I've seen it
it's doing like this we get this side
and then the other side we got it
awesome thank you thank you so much
now if you think that [ __ ] would have
happened in 2009 you're out of your
[ __ ] brains market in the year that
we actually live in so Gary what's your
name
I'm hi I'm Cheryl Barone hey Cheryl so
four years ago you came to see us in eyo
New Jersey and you convinced me to
establish our footprint from George's
expectation go ahead and so people now
think our company is much larger than it
really is because of that so that was an
awesome event you know so he did affect
us at least so now I'm asking you we
need to recruit freight agents to join
our company and looking you know how
could we use Instagram and snapchat and
stuff like that to do recruiting and get
our name out there because that I'm
really not able to figure out our
windows you go to LinkedIn you should
search freight agents or whatever title
they would use you should map all those
people you should run LinkedIn ads to
target them specifically you should also
take those names put them in Google add
the word Twitter and start talking to
them you will convert that scale great
welcome thank you hey Gary
David from IO New York you came as well
for you I guess you were on tour and you
inspired me then I didn't think I was
gonna learn anything new today because I
said I saw him four years ago what am I
gonna learn too and I I was really
unbelievable so one of the things that I
think you talked about a lot of great
things one of the things that I feel was
not talked about was the actual message
yeah and I think that's because you're
so authentic
that's sort of I think helped your grand
but your brand grow our target market is
lawyers yeah so we're on LinkedIn we're
in AdWords right now
yep I haven't felt like it would be
authentic enough to go on Instagram or
Vaughn and yes I don't even use them but
I guess not specifically for me but for
everyone one of the things that I find
when we go on Facebook or we go on that
what do we do here's a discount code
here's this here's that and I feel that
it would be sort of yes lawyers are
people but sometimes I feel it's hard to
listen and have to stand out from the
crowd from all of us bad marketers
just saying discount code discount code
discount code so what is the view how do
you let all be authentic in Iran yeah
first I have a serious question yeah
because that kind of blew my mind
lawyers are people can you flash the
book cover real quick if you guys don't
mind thanks for the question I
appreciate the setup this entire book is
predicated on your question the reason I
wrote this book is you're getting to the
real crux of the issue which is the
creative is the variable of the
conversion right so what I did there was
that I did a textbook for an F student
it's 120 case studies of what's good and
bad content on all those platforms you
could take it off got it so let's get
into that for a second I first have to
convince you guys that this is where the
attention of the consumer is this is why
I love doing QA cuz you've set me up for
the comma the next part now if you
believe you actually have to know how to
story tell on Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram and one thing a lot
of you do because I looked at some of
the people using the hashtag for this
event yesterday I looked at their
accounts and their businesses you use
the same picture and the same copy on
Facebook as you do a Twitter you even do
the dumbest thing in the world which is
you connect your Facebook and Twitter
account so copy goes to both places
because you've defaulted into thinking
that social media is distribution but
what they are is their platforms to
actually story tell and you're
disrespecting the psychology of the
person in the platform when a 40 year
old woman or a 22 year old woman is on
Pinterest her psychology is
window-shopping 3.0 when she's on
Facebook she's keeping up with her world
that has a different psychology you need
a different message you said the real
thing my man
lawyers are people and so you have a way
better chance of closing a lawyer
talking about fishing and golf and
football and cooking or whatever the
[ __ ] they care about and oh by the way
facebook knows what they care about and
creating contextual ads that matter
because we have tuned out the hard sell
that right hook in that book it's hard
to land because we've all stopped Jabby
and when you know the right hooks coming
you duck and so the creative is the
variable
yes I'm authentic but I spend all my
time trying to figure out what you want
nothing else you know yes I have bravado
and confidence and ego and whatever it
is so it makes it easier for me to do my
thing but it's not really not that hard
to do it's just that we want to say what
we want to say versus we want to say
what the other person wants humans are
flawed and humans are the ones that are
making the marketing decisions and
that's why so much marketing sucks [ __ ]
you got brother hey hey
boar is it more thick [ __ ] ooh [ __ ]
ooh yes [ __ ] awesome
so much my name is Portia we do we can
work on that we we do b2b stuff and I
have trouble deciding sometimes when to
go after stuff with my personal social
media yeah or like the company social me
yep so where do you kind of like draw
that line or how do you pick and go
after stuff you know that's a good
question the truth is that's an
intuition game right that's like just a
pure intuition game like there's not
enough con me if I sat and looked at the
context and you're like here the 15
leads I think I'd have good intuition to
figure out where to go but that's that's
like raw talent right that's like asking
LeBron how to drop 33 you know like you
know I don't know like if I can do it
like you know like I mean there's that's
a tough one because that is really
instinctual sales and you have a feel
for the customer and which you know
that's understanding that you know
that's me understanding that six people
in this room didn't like this talk
because they were clouded by the dirty
mouth and I made them check out and
that's okay I respect that I really do
it's tact it's understanding and so
you've got to figure that out for you
more based on them than you back to the
last answer right guys I'm pissed that I
have to leave because I feel like we
could have really jammed for an hour and
I have no idea who's speaking after me
but they're clearly not gonna be as good
and so and I'm just kidding I'm sorry
for others figure and I wish you guys
health and unhappiness thank you
thank you